water
[Music]
from the creators of The Last Airbender
comes the story of a new generation what
makes you so sure your daughter is the
one
that was a 2000 year old
historical treasure whoops it's time for
your generation to take on the
responsibility of keeping peace and
balance in world
your best friend is a polar bear-dog
somehow that makes perfect sense
who do you think you are why don't you
come and find out
the era of rending is over
Republic city does need you but it needs
me too
I will destroy you I've never felt like
this before I don't know what to do it's
okay to be scared
there's no place in the world for you
anymore
count us out just yet the legend of
welcome back everyone is Charlie big
surprise Netflix just made a big
announcement about the future of the
avatar series we have the new Avatar The
Last Airbender series that Mike and
Brian are doing the brand-new episodes
that will probably be coming late next
year early 2021 but Netflix also
announced that all the chorus stuff is
now coming to Netflix - previously was
just the classic series since they're
doing a brand new version of the classic
series a lot of you've also asked me if
they would do the same thing for Legend
of Korra after that because there's only
three books worth of episodes for the
classic series so we'll explain what
Mike and Bryan have said about that and
other future animated projects it'll
explain what happened to team aang
between the events of avatar the last
airbenders finale sozin's comet in the
beginning of korra season 1 because it's
over 70 years worth of history and
they've really only glossed over that so
far like what happened to Aang how did
he die what happened to the rest of the
squad because some of the older team
aang members like Zuko Toph and Katara
did show up in the core episodes so
starting with number 5 the first thing
that happened to team avatar right after
the finale was Zuko was crowned Fire
Lord and you have the events of the
promise comic book it takes place just a
little while after the events of the
finale so not a lot of time has gone by
the promise title is a reference to the
promise that Aang and Zuko make to
ensure that something like the hundred
year war with the Fire Nation never
happens again
and the symbol of that promise
eventually becomes Republic City as you
see it during Legend of Korra now it
took a long time to build that city but
eventually they pick a site it's meant
to be this neutral sort of territory
between all the nations and kingdoms
where the world lives in harmony at
least that was the idea when they
started building it for everyone that
saw the Korra episode there's an awful
lot of war that happens inside Republic
City for it to be this peaceful place
that I intended it to be but during this
period in history there's a couple
skirmishes and border tensions between
the Fire Nation and other kingdoms
because the wars only just ended so
tempers are pretty high Zuko goes to see
his father Fire Lord Ozai while he's in
prison they talk about the fate of his
mother he gets some details about what
happened to her they just leave him to
question what really happened you also
find out what happened to Azula right
after the finale she got locked up for
her own safety mostly because she went
completely crazy during the
the finale after the Agni Kai still
super crazy that doesn't change in Toph
starts her metalbending school that will
eventually evolve into the metalbender
city within the earth Kingdom where her
future daughter suyin will live but Toph
is canonically the first human metal
bender in the avatar universe that we
know about so she gets full credit for
inventing metalbending number 4 that a
little bit of time goes by and you have
the events of the search comic book the
title of the search is a reference to
Zuko's search for his mother they
eventually do find her in Azula uses the
opportunity to go with them and escape
so she goes off into the wild and is
running around the world but initially
what happened is is that Zuko as a child
believe that his mother abandoned them
and he and Azula grew up thinking that
she didn't love them and he just
believed what he was told I think that
was just to make his backstory as sad as
possible growing up believing that his
mother didn't love him
what they find is is the true story
behind IRS's disappearance that's the
name of Sukkos mother is that she didn't
abandon her children she was forced to
leave is because in the past she learns
that Fire Lord Ozai father fire lord
azulon had actually ordered Ozai to kill
Zuko his punishment for Ozai asking to
be made heir to the throne following the
death of arrows son in the siege of Ba
Sing se everyone cried a little bit and
think about leaves on the vine she
discovers that Ozai was going to comply
with as laws demand because he wanted to
be Fire Lord no matter what in order to
save Zuko's life his mother offers to
provide Ozai with an untraceable poison
which he could use to kill özil on his
father and then become Fire Lord that
way
Ozai agrees on the condition that Ursa
would leave the city and never return so
that nobody could find out that he
secretly killed his father
the second condition was that Ozai
forced Ursa to leave Azula and Zuko
behind without giving her the
opportunity to tell them why she was
leaving they knows I would keep them
close to him as hostages as collateral
against her should she ever try to come
back and out him for what he did
Zucco's eventually reunited with her
they find out - she'd actually use the
mother of faces ability to literally
change her face and erase her memories
of the past so that she could start over
completely with the new life is someone
different she eventually got remarried
she's living a happy life when Zuko
finds her but she agrees to get her
memory
back from the mother of faces then once
she does and she remembers Zucco she
apologizes to him for letting him
believe that she'd abandoned him they
reconcile and she continues to live her
new life with Zuko going back to the
Fire Nation understanding that she still
loves him so they get sort of a happy
ending and then during the smoke and
shadow they addressed what happened to
Azula after she escaped she continues to
grow up but comes back to harass Zuko
every once in a while trying to make him
more in more hardcore become
quote-unquote the Fire Lord she knows
that he can be the number three we
learned what happened to Toph who went
on to have two daughters from two
different men her older daughter Lin
beifong and younger daughter suyin
beifong both big characters during
Legend of Korra we only learned the
identity of Lin's father in the fact
that soohyun's father was a different
man
a lot of people had wondered if Sokka
ever got together with Toph and was one
of her baby daddies just because there
was some implied chemistry between them
in the original series some shipping
moments but they never fully answered
that question so neither men nor soohyun
know their fathers growing up tops first
husband was actually an earthbender
named Kanto who died when she was
pregnant with Lyn then several years
later she has a relationship with
another mystery man getting pregnant
with suyun but the way that Toph
explains it in her old age is that that
man left her just because he couldn't
deal with it Mike and Brian haven't
revealed who the second baby daddy was
but a lot of people want to believe that
it's Sokka in in present-day his
whereabouts are still kind of
unconfirmed you don't find out how he
died but Katara implies that he might be
dead so it is possible this Sokka really
is su Ian's father but that would mean
that Toph was lying to her daughters
talking about him as a man quote-unquote
who left her when she was pregnant
because Sokka would never leave Toph
when she was pregnant
now if Sokka were to die while Toph was
pregnant and he did have that child with
her that's a different matter but the
comics haven't fully answered that
question yet so you're still kind of
left to wonder number two Aang and
Katara started their family having three
children
tenzin bumi and kya all really big
legend of korra characters kya was a
waterbender Tenzin was an airbender and
when he was old enough because he was
the oldest child he actually got to
travel the world with Eng while he was
an adult as the avatar just putting out
fires all over the world
Bumi he didn't manifest any airbending
powers till late in his life so when he
was younger he joined the military
eventually became a general but then
retired to live with his family then
when all the airbenders started
manifesting during Korra book 3 he gets
airbending abilities too and officially
joins the new airbending nation the
reason that Aang do young though he died
when he was around 66 biologically not
that old he died because of the physical
toll being in the Avatar State for over
a hundred years took on his body when he
was stuck in the ice so you have to
remember that chronologically he died
when he was a hundred and sixty-six
years old his body just gave out from
being so taxed but number one I know a
lot of you are also asking me will they
do a new live-action Legend of Korra
after the new live-action Avatar The
Last Airbender Netflix series that
they're making right now my assumption
is is that Netflix wants to use this as
their big game of Thrones level
programming their big Disney Plus killer
so they probably want as much new avatar
as possible and Mike and Bryan imply
that there might also be future animated
projects said in the Avatar universe so
it's not that they're just doing this
new live-action avatar the last
airbender series there might also be
more animation in the distant future
because it's taken them years to develop
just this first live-action Avatar The
Last Airbender series if they do
eventually do live-action Korra that
would probably be way way down the road
in any new animation projects would be
after that too
so for at least the next several years
is just gonna be about this brand new
avatar the last airbender Netflix series
but if you have any other questions
about the avatar lore or any bonus
videos that you want me to do just let
me know in the comments I did do a lot
of Legend of Korra episode videos but it
was way back when I first started my
channel so the videos seem very
different from the type of videos that I
make now you can click here for all my
avatar the last airbender videos and my
Legend of Korra episode videos and click
here for that new Spider Man into the
spider-verse
2 teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]